we tend to think of health and fitness
advice and practices as fixed this is
far from the truth our health practices
are constantly changing to reflect the
times and the advice we are given and
tools we use have huge impacts on the
way we feel and move
it's crazy to think now but until the
1960s seeing someone jogging down the
street would have seemed absurd
going to the gym wasn't a regular
activity until the likes of arnold
schwarzenegger made it popular heck if
you go back to the 17th century by
phasic sleep was common while evidence
is lacking it's possible according to
the book sleep in early modern england
that 17th century brits also used to
sleep sitting up
beer was once the beverage of choice to
combat unclean water and many think that
the rise of caffeine during the advent
of the renaissance period was no
coincidence
these shifts have been seismic
so let's take a journey into the future
of health and fitness let's see how we
might perform train and live in 10 20 50
and 100 years from now
2025
the year is 2025 and things seem the
same on the surface however over the
past three to four years there's been a
noticeable shift towards functional
fitness
people are finally starting to train
because they recognize that it can help
them to move more freely more
energetically without pain and for
longer
this is partly a reaction to world
events ever since the great pandemic of
2020 more people than ever have remained
working from home in so many ways the
pandemic has simply accelerated the
inevitable social change
without a commute or social interaction
with colleagues many of us started to
see our health and fitness decline
movement is the only antidote to such an
activity and so we find ourselves now
engaging in a more varied range of
activities more people a trail running
training with kettlebells and rope
climbing right in their backyards or
local parks
gym memberships are down but we're
getting fitter nonetheless
reality is increasingly an important
part of our training too the oculus
quest 3 is broken into the mainstream
and fitness apps are system sellers that
made this possible the game changing
feature here is hand and foot tracking
as well as a lighter and more
form-fitting headset with superior
pass-through and augmented reality
features
popular apps include a treadmill running
app that challenges the user to raise
shadows of themselves and their friends
2035
another 10 years have passed and the way
we train has continued down this path
and with so many people now working from
home it's increasingly common to train
multiple times throughout the day in
sporadic bursts movement is increasingly
baked into our lifestyles
and we're beginning to see this change
reflected in the designs of our homes
instead of designing a property to be as
comfortable as possible many are now
intentionally placing obstacles and
challenges in their own way why walk up
the stairs when you could traverse up
the adjacent wall why not add a low
passage in the hallway to encourage a
little bit of crawling it's rare to see
someone wearing shoes with souls anymore
we're beginning to recognize that the
body craves complexity and that it is
capable of remarkable rejuvenation when
we just get out of its way
gyms are making a comeback with an
entirely different approach immersive
virtual reality training examples
include rock climbing experiences that
use resistance machines and moving grips
to simulate a treacherous rock climb
with a breathtaking view and a bike ride
through an impossible twisting highway
in the sky
our rainbow road
2040 our work-life balance is now
greater than ever before many of us work
for just a few hours a day before
closing our computers and getting on
with life this has increased the need
though for us to find our own meaning in
life in the year 2040 we are encouraged
to treat our mental health in the same
way we treat our physical health
just as it is normal to brush our teeth
get fresh air and exercise on a regular
basis so too is it now a given that we
must set aside some time each week to
learn move spend time with friends spend
time immersed in nature get sun exposure
meditate
meditation itself is undergoing a
transformation with research
experimenting with new approaches to see
how they can affect brain function far
more advanced health tracking devices
let us know when we need more sleep and
warn us about ambient light or noise
that might be affecting that sleep
quality what's more is that the absolute
ubiquity of iot that's internet of
things means that many processes in our
homes are now plugged directly into our
biometrics ambient temperature changes
to keep us at a permanently optimum
temperature
tiny chips installed everywhere ensure
that problems with air quality is
detected before they can do us any harm
we're increasingly seeing homes with
large open spaces huge skylights and
conservatories with retractable roofs
far more focus is placed on garden
spaces we are increasingly encouraged to
keep our windows open and to turn off
the central heating not only does this
open-air design allow us to get sun
exposure and regulate our biological
clocks but it also creates a far
healthier bacteria profile various once
common illnesses are becoming rarer as a
result
many of us now have dedicated sunni
spots in our homes some of these utilize
red light devices
xr training meanwhile that's vr or ar
training has moved outside with a
greater emphasis on augmented reality we
can run around our garden collecting
orbs get chased down the street by
zombies fights imaginary enemies and
contort ourselves to avoid incoming
laser fire
training is no longer tedious or boring
with a focus on increasing specific
numbers for their own sake training is
play we're living out our heroic
fantasies and exploring amazing
impossible places meanwhile indoor vr
training options now include advanced
biomechanical sensory capabilities that
is to say that your vr app now
understands your precise weight
distribution and the position of every
limb and joint this can be used to
perfect posture and even coach a number
of advanced movements without any need
for face-to-face coaching certain
transhuman technologies are making their
way to the black market injections that
alter dna to suppress myostatin are
increasingly being used in the way that
steroids once were
however they are illegal unsafe and
banned by almost all sports
2050
several new laws have been introduced to
drastically reduce the amount of
processed food available as the
nutritional value of the average snack
has improved so is the health of the
general population many countries now
place objective happiness ratings as the
measure of successful policies rather
than gdp many people now live in small
communes it's common to live near to
your friends and family and to spend
time socializing with them outdoors in
shared communal areas homes are now
augmented reality experiences in
themselves each wall and surface can
project an unlimited array of high
fidelity scenes complete with natural
light and immersive sound imagine going
to sleep under a blanket of stars or
waking up to a serene waterfall scene
this is convenient as the weather
outside has become increasingly hostile
medication and supplementation are now
personalized and dictated by advanced
genetic screening and testing regular
checkups ensure that we get all the
nutrients we need and any deficiencies
are dealt with early the athletes of
2050 seem truly superhuman compared with
those from 2020 this is not due to the
introduction of any new super
supplements but rather better training
and identification genetic screening
means that we can now detect those
individuals with never-before-seen
traits at an early age these are not
just common desirable variants called
snps or snips but rather entirely novel
genetic mutations these are one in a
billion individuals who can build more
muscle run faster and avoid injury
has this destroyed the notion that
anyone can become a top level athlete
with the right training and opportunity
perhaps but the genie is truly out of
the bottle now on top of this those same
athletes are now bolstered by augmented
reality imagine a device that can
provide real-time feedback during
training that could pinpoint the precise
angle of a throw and the necessary speed
and angle change that would have made it
perfect imagine how a system like this
might use lights and sounds to tap into
the dopamine system and naturally
encourage adaptation and change
we are increasingly learning to tap into
brain plasticity helping the brain and
body to achieve things we never thought
possible and what do you know the way to
do this looks very much like playing a
video game
2075 what about gene modification what
about the cyberpunk future we were
promised
these technologies ultimately failed to
reach the mainstream even once gene
multiplication could be safely
accomplished we were never able to fully
comprehend the true complexity of the
human brain or body every small tweak
has countless knock-on effects in an
interconnected system that is simply
complex beyond our reckoning myostatin
suppression comes with a risk of tendon
damage and heart issues it can change
your mood smart drugs or neurotropics
that once showed such promise never
managed to facilitate optimal cognitive
performance without a cascade of
negative effects
the much vaunted flow state was a fool's
gold there is not one optimal brain
state the brain works best when it's
able to naturally flow from one state to
another
augmentations and prosthetics while
increasingly amazing still can't come
close to the level of dexterity or
sensory resolution present in human
tissue
similar challenges led to the closure of
neuralink the brain is not a
straightforward input output machine in
some individuals entire functions of the
brain can migrate to other regions and
the complexity of even a single neuron
is beyond our understanding as
demonstrated by short-term plasticity
and dendritic computation
the research conducted in the name of
neuralink led to some breakthroughs
though the threading process being
invaluable for many disabled patients
but this was not the step change in
communication that was promised nor did
a commercially viable product ever come
forward the notion that we need more
bandwidth was insightful but ultimately
this same challenge was overcome with a
more efficient input method gona qwerty
keyboards today children are taught via
video games to use devices that allow
them to enter complex sentences with
just a few keystrokes
meanwhile computers themselves now use
biological parts that are capable of
seemingly impossible data storage and
processing
the future of fitness came more from
tapping into what we already have rather
than trying to change our biology
ultimately the very definition of what
it means to be healthy has shifted the
average healthy person will never feel
tired they'll never experience chronic
pain and they will be free from many
conditions that were once commonplace
and far from being a dull requirement
many of us now see training and play as
one and the same a view bolstered
immeasurably by the role of virtual and
augmented reality
and we have reached the singularity
machine learning and big data have
advanced to the point that they are
finally able to correctly second guess
the cascading effects of the most tiny
alterations to the human genetic code
the human body and brain remain a black
box to us but the machines we've created
nevertheless provide the necessary form
of abstraction we can finally visualize
changes that we might make to the human
body as we might use a character
creation screen in a computer game
and not a moment too soon with the
environment burning around us changing
our bodies in a shorter time frame than
evolution would ever allow is the only
way to survive
that and retreating through the
superstructures we've built under the
sea and exploration vessels destined for
the stars
many heavily altered humans evacuate the
earth for a partially terraformed mars
and a fresh start for a new offshoot of
humanity
so you found this video useful and
interesting guys it was something a bit
different there these are my predictions
for the future of fitness and health
obviously i don't think all of this will
happen but i think a lot of it certainly
could happen and i think the aim for us
is to try and get ahead of the curve and
to train in a way that we might do given
another 10 or 20 years of education
that's obviously the idea behind this
channel in many ways and the idea behind
my training program and ebook super
functional training you can find a link
in the description down below and
there's a discount on right now during
the pandemic alternatively if you just
want to learn about functional training
then you can also check out my book
functional training and beyond that's a
print book and it's available from all
good book stores but you'll probably
need to ask them to get it in stock for
you either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys we'll be back to
our usual programming next time leave a
like and share around if you want to
help out that's a huge help to me in the
channel and subscribe if you want more
like this hit the bell button if you
want to be notified of future uploads
thanks again guys and i'll see you next
time
bye for now
[Music]